in 2010 this man forever changed the
lives of cyber criminals and cyber
Security Experts programmer baraby Jack
discovered a serious vulnerability in
ATMs worldwide the problem lay here in
the upper circuit where the computer is
located if the lower unit is a reliable
safe then the upper one opens with a
universal key and it can be purchased on
the dark web Barnaby shocked the
audience at the black hack conference
with two attacks first he opened the
units and uploaded malicious software he
developed just a few
clicks and then he explained how a
criminal could access A bank's internal
system and force any ATM to dispense
cash no personal information no
fingerprints complete anonymity banks
around the world feared that criminals
would be inspired by Barnaby's report
and that's exactly what's
happened but that's a different
story